تتصاعد التوترات في البحر الاسود منذ
انسحاب روسيا من اتفاق الحبوب اواسط يوليو
تموز الماضي ومع ارتفاع منسوب التوتر في
البحر الاسود ترتفع المخاوف من اتساع رقعه
الصراع وما قد يترتب عليها من تداعيات
كارثيه على الامن الغذائي العالمي الى اين
تتجه الحرب المستعره فوق مياه البحر
الاسود وهل تنجح انقره في مساعيها الراميه
لاقناع موسكو بالعوده الى اتفاق تصدير
الحبوب وكيف سيؤثر اي رفض روسي لتجديد
الاتفاق على الامن الغذائي العالمي كان
سوق الغذاء ووضع الامن الغذائي لا يكفي
حتى تاتي الغاء مبادره او اتفاقيه مبادره
البحر الاسود ومن ثم الخوض والوصول الى
تدمير المخزون الاستراتيجي والمغازي
الموجوده المنشات الموجوده في الموانع
الاوكرانيه هذا كله يعمق من الخوف والقلق
في سوق الغذاء هذا التصعيد من وجهه النظر
روسيه ما الذي يمكن ان يقود اليه روسيا
هدفها
تنفيذ المذكره التي هي وقعتها مع الامم
المتحده ولكن للاسف الشديد هذه
المذكره صارت مثل مذكره سوء التفاهم لان
كلاء الطرفين لديهما استفسار خاص الامم
المتحده تقول انها هي تبذل الجهود
لتنفيذ هذه المذكره روسيا تقول عن عندها
حوالي خمس بنود للط لم يتم
تنفيذ مطالب روسيا فلذلك يبدو ان روسيا
اتخذت قرارا حاسما بعدما
مددت مذكره البحر الاسود طلات مرات هذه
المره اتخذت قرارا حاسما للقضاء على هذه
الصفقه ومن الصاب التخيل انه قريبا سيتم
انعاش هذه الصفقه دون
المتطلبات الروسيه هل سيجعل مهمه تركيا في
العوده لاتفاق الحبوب اكثر تعقيدا بالضبط
اعتقد ذلك كما تعلمون ان روسيا كررت في
السابق سحابها من اتفاق الحبوب وبالتالي
ليست المره اوللا لكن هذه المره اعت
القياده السياسيه في روسيا هذه المره
اكثرت جديه وعازمون على عدم العوده الى
مائده المفاوضات هناك ثلاثه ادعاءات لد
الجانب الروسي احدها ان هناك بعض المشاكل
في
تدفق الاموال الناجمه عن هذا عن تصدير
الحبوب
والثاني
الحظر المفروض على تصدير الاسوده الروسيه
والدعاء الثالث هو ان الدول الفقيره لم
تستفد بما
من هذه الصفقه وبالتالي هذه تساؤلات
رئيسيه يطرحها الجانب الروسي لحد الان هو
نوع من الابتزاز وفي نفس الوقت نوع من
الاستغراب بانك تطلب من جهه شيئا لا تملكه
هذه عقوبات غربيه وليست عقوبات ام المتحده
ولا تركيه اذا هنا احنا وقعنا في اشكال كل
ما سوف تحصل عليه هو الوعد هل فعلا
المساله قد تكون وشيكه لا اعتقد ذلك صراحه
لان على رغم الجانب التركي يسعى لذلك
لترويج هذه الفكره
وانعش هذه المبادره ولكن حطى الان
القيادات الروسيه مصممه في قرارها واعتقد
انه لن يخدث ذلك قريبا لان الغرب لا
يتنازل وايضا موسكو تدرك جيدا ان اردوغان
لا يملك القوه الكافيه للضغط على الولايات
المتحده وعلى الامم المتحده تركيا والرئيس
اردوغان يواجهان تحديا
اكبر اذ يبدو ان الامور ستكون صعبه جدا
لسوء الحظ تركيا والرئيس اردوغان في هذه
المرحله هم الامل الوحيد للعالم وجانب
جانبين المتحاربين لاجل حل هذه الازمه
وكما قلت سابقا الاولويه بالنسبه للدول
الغربيه خاصه الولايات المتحده مختلفه
تماما وبالتالي عندما ننظر الى الارض نجد
ان صفقه الحوب هذه هي مساله انسانيه ان لم
تحل فانها ستؤدي الى ضرر كبير جديد كبير
بالنسبه للدول
الفقيره عندي بعض من التوقعات والاسباب
روسيا بهذه الاتفاقيه عندما الغتها يعني
كان لها امل بان يتم الغاء هذه الاتفاقيه
لتحقيق مطالبها التي كانت دائما من توعد
بها ولما شافت انه ما في اي استجاب بدات
في ضرب الطرق الاخرى للتصدير روسيا تكسب
كثيرا من وجود تركيا اللي يقضوا في في
الاطلسي في جانبها فلذلك
ما راح تترك تركيا خاليه الوفاض وبالتالي
راح تعطيها هذا الدور لانه هذا الدور
يعتبر نوع من القوه اللي حليف ل دوله
داعمه
المشكله الان تكمن في الاستغلال التجاري
بهذا الموضوع والاستغلال السياسي هذه
بورصه اي حاله عدم يقين اي خبر مثلها مثل
اي بورصه عالميه حتى الاستغلال السياسي
بدون قصد وقعت فييه الامم المتحده بدات
تستغل الموضوع بشكل سياسي الامم المتحده
لما يجي برنامج الغذائي العالمي يقول لك
انا اشتريت من اوكرانيا وطعمت هي الدول طب
انت عندك كل دول العالم بتشتري منها يعني
عندك رومانيا اللي هي جنب اوكرانيا
وبلغاريا اللي هي جنب اوكرانيا انت تشتري
منها الروس يلعبون لعبه حكيمه جدا مع
الجنوب الجماعي خاصه مع الدول الافريقيه
الدول
الافريقيه تدرك جيدا هناك الرسومات
البيانيه الدائريه للامم المتحده انه من
اجمالي
33 مليون طن من الصادرات الاوكرانيه في
العام الماضي فقط 4 ملايين طن ذهبت الى
افريقيا ما هي اكثر الدول التي ستتضرر
اكثر من غيرها معظمها في دول غرب اسيا
ودول وسط افريقيا وقليلا في الكاريبي لكن
بشكل اساسي هذه الدول لانه وضعها سيء
ووضعها المادي ايضا وال الاقتصادي خليني
اسميه ايضا لا يؤهلها لمجراه هذه الصدمه
في الاسعار علينا ان نمي
بين السياسه والازمات
الانسانيه فهناك ازمت متوازيتان حاليا
اعتقد ليس بامكان اي دوله واحده بما ذلك
روسيا وال الغرب يمكن لا يمكن يبق لا لا
يبالون بما يحصل في العالم وازمه الغذاء
في العالم لابد للجانبين ان
يتفقا على التوصل الى حل ا كان الحل خفيف
ازمه الغذاء في
[موسيقى]
العالم